To know in Spanish is saber, saber.
Saber.
You may have heard in British language he's got savi, she's got savi.
Have you ever heard that?
Yeah
And that comes from Latin actually.
That slang is coming from Latin.
Saber is to know.
He's got saber.
He's got savi.
Saber is spelt with a B, but in English we are saying sabi with a V.
So we're seeing even that connection between the sounds of V and B, crossing between English and Spanish, saber, sabi.
So saber is to know.
So if you want to say I want to know.
Quiero saber.
How would you say I don't want to know?
No quiero saber.
Good.
How would you say he wants to know or she wants to know?
Or your fullman want to know?
Saber.
Good.
You change the O to E and you get quiere.
Quiere saber.
He doesn't want to know.
No quiere saber.
Why doesn't he want to know?
I want to know why he doesn't want to know.
Very good.
Very good
The word for yes in Spanish is si.
Si.
This is also the word for if
So how do you say if?
C.
Good.
I want to know if you want to know.
Of course we're speaking formally.
This is the one we learned so far.
I want to know if you want to know
Quiero saber si quieres saber.
Good.
Quiero saber si quiere saber.
I want to know if he wants to invite me.
So the first bit is I want to know.
Quiero saber.
Saber B sound, because it's a B here.
If C he wants to invite me.
So you see, if you think about it block by block, it's very simple.
If we think slowly, we learn very quickly and the process gets much faster.
How do you say imagination?
Imaginacion.
Good.
I don't want to imagine.
I don't want to imagine it
No quiero imaginarlo.
Good.
What was to come?
And we said that we can remember if we look at convenient, conveniente, which is like with coming.
Venir.
Good.
I want to know if she wants to come to the house to visit me.
So again, it might be something that looks overwhelming that we can't say, but if we divide it up, I want to know.
Quiero saber if
See.
She wants to come.
Quiere venir to the house.
A la casa.
Good.
To visit me
Ah visitar me.
Cut you put arm there.
Because even now we have a la casa
there in between, you you stayed with the feeling of the near and you wanted to connect it to the next verb and you are one hundred percent correct to do that.
I want to know why she doesn't want to come to the house to visit me.
I want to know
Quiero saber.
Saber.
Why?
Porque she doesn't want.
No quiere to come to the house.
Venir a la casa?
To visit me.
A visitarme.
Good.
Very good.
Well done.
Quiero saber por qué no quiere venir a la casa a visitarme.
Very good.
So what we most want to take away from this is the confidence to try to say what we are almost sure we cannot say because we have this wonderful advantage.
As English speakers, that we have so much vocabulary that we can convert over to Spanish that we won't realize we can convert over to Spanish until we try it.
I will just give you now a couple of sentences for listening practice.
What does it mean if I say
voy a invitarlo, pero no voy a invitarlo ahora.
What did I say?
First, is voy a invitarlo.
I'm going to invite them.
Lo.
Oh, you.
Oh.
It could be you, you fumel.
You fummel or him.
Yeah.
Boy invitando.
Or it if it can make some sense.
I'm going to invite it.
Voy a invitarlo, pero muy espero.
But, but no voy a invitarlo ahora.
But I won't invite him now.
Very good.
Quiero iniciarlo ahora.
I want to start now.
Good.
And something missing though.
Quiero iniciarlo ahora.
I want to start it now.
Good.
Quiere iniciarlo ahora.
You want or he wants?
Good.
Or she wants.
Why doesn't he want to let me know?
To inform me.
Yeah, perfect.
But this is perfect what you did.
You found uh you got the meaning or you said it how it's comfortable for you in English?
Exactly.
Why doesn't he want to inform me?
Why doesn't he want to let me know?
Perfect
How is a justification in Spanish?
Is it a gh sound?
Good.
Yes.
If it's j so it's justificacion to justify.
Justificar.
I'm not trying to justify myself.
What is myself in Spanish?
Me.
Yes, same as me.
Same as me.
So I'm not trying.
No intento justificarlo.
No, justificarme.
Good.
No intento justificarme.
But I want to explain.
Now explain is an exception.
We have explanation in English, but this in Spanish is explicacion.
It changes.
So it's an exception.
We don't say explanacion but explicación.
We have this in English as well.
We have in English inexplicable.
How do you say that in Spanish?
Yes.
We have even in English this root of the C sound we've explained.
We say explain, but then we say inexplicable.
So explanation is explicacion in Spanish.
So how is to explain?
Explicar.
So but I want to explain.
Pero quiero explicar.
Good.
Do you remember how to say something?
Algo.
Algo, well done.
But I want to explain you something.
In English maybe it's more common we would say I want to explain something to you.
But in Spanish we can just say but
I want to explain you something and let's say it informally.
So what was the word for you for informal?
We can remember it from I love you, yes, te, te quiero.
So, but I want to explain you something.
Very good.
Let's say it all together.
I'm not trying to justify myself, but I want to explain something to you.
So I'm not trying is the first bit.
Now I want 100% of your mental energy on
I'm not trying.
All of your attention on I'm not trying.
Then we look at the next bit and we forget I'm not trying.
Once we've said it, we don't need to hold it.
I'm not trying.
No intento.
To justify myself
Justificar me.
Good, we can forget that bit.
But Pero I want Qiero to explain you
Explicate something.
Algo.
Very good.
No intento justificarme, pero
Quiero explicarte algo.
Very good.
Well done.